hey what's up bill burr I'm out here
right now Glendale California you know
when I think is stand up that's what I
think they'll show the name of the place
because I'm gonna all over it
came out here to go do this gig I got I
got a Letterman set coming up on the
21st the Jews I figured come out here
run my five minutes and it's a
hell room in there there's like 40
people all sitting at the same table and
everybody is going up eating their balls
and that guy just wave like he just put
his hand up like no no don't put me on
camera cos I put my camera I'm
officially retired ghost funny about
California who's probably on like mash
for like nine seasons but anyways why am
I doing this video I'm trying to hack my
podcast I do the Monday morning podcast
every every Monday huh and it's on Bill
burr calm and the fan page is the MM
podcast.com a cameraman just mom mouthed
it to me
I couldn't even say that so I'm gonna go
in here eat my balls is the host right
there Larry what's up my up next he's
wrapping up a few minutes okay okay yep
feel his nervousness that's what's going
on in there listen to the podcast every
Monday and let's probably up on the mmm
podcast so tell your friends to come to
this to this page because we're gonna
try to blow it up trying to make it go
viral whatever you kids say